ma belle vanessa grenier pour moi
l'enjeu le plus important au québec
c'est l'environnement
je m'appelle benoît arcand mes
préoccupations pendant la campagne
électorale c'est la famille
l'environnement et l'éducation
je m'appelle mire dans boileau et mes
deux préoccupations principales pour les
prochaines élections c'est la parité
hommes femmes et la protection de la
langue française
alors bonjour à vous trois meriane 18
ans oui il va voter pour la première
fois 1er octobre et a envie de voter
et oui oui vraiment ouais je suis un
succès ça fait quand même longtemps que
la pensée de pouvoir voter à 18 ans
fille qui enfin le moment est ce que
c'est de voir est ce que c'est un devoir
bonjour donné ça va jouer un devoir de
voter vous voulez voter oui je pense
qu'il m'aime moi oui ça fait depuis des
cas plus que 18 ans puis c'est à peu
près le seul
la seule possibilité qu'on a de faire un
peu entendre notre voix fait que je
pense que des passes à côté de ce moment
là c'est un peu plus diot donc oui je
prends je prends cette possibilité là
qui s'offre à moi d'une faute en 20 ans
benoît 31 ans bonjour bonjour je serais
bien oui comédiens journée sur la
culture exactement donc effectivement
vous avez eu des changes de voter
souvent dans votre vie à 31 ans par m
c'est ma troisième année dans le fond où
j'ai le droit de voter puis moi aussi
j'ai eu la chance à 18 ans de voter pour
la première fois est ce que vous faites
par devoir vous le faire parce que vous
avez l'impression que ça change quelque
chose
il serait plus ça avance plus j'ai
l'impression c'est par devoir
c'est un peu triste peut-être un peu là
pourquoi donc
j'ai l'impression que plus ça a très
justement dans les 13 dernières années
j'ai l'impression que les plateformes
électorales sont de plus en plus à court
terme puis on voit pour les quatre
prochaines années
on lui d'avoir des projets à long terme
de quand même des grands enjeux dans
cette campagne là je vous êtes étudiante
au doctorat en biologie
donc forcément l'environnement est
globalement chez les jeunes
l'environnement c'est un dossier
important
c'est votre cas oui mais je suis
biologiste mais je travaille en
environnement directement dans la
gestion des matières résiduelles et la
décontamination des sols donc oui
l'environnement pour moi c'est un peu
aberrant même que ça se retrouve dans
une plate forme électorale
c'est un besoin essentiel je besoin de
préserver l'environnement comme benoît
xvi pour les générations futures
ça devrait même pas faire partie des
deux premières devrait juste être là et
tout le monde devrait se donner la main
puis avancer ensemble dans cette
direction le pauvre s'assurer que dans
50 ans on est encore là vous avez des
dossiers qui vous tiennent à coeur
particulièrement la parité oui oui oui
vraiment j'ai failli mettre
l'environnement dans mes préoccupations
principales
mais je trouvais important la parité
homme femme parce que surtout en fait
avec le mouvement moi aussi à l'automne
dernier puis avec le hashtag agression
dénoncée en 2014 je pense que c'est un
sujet vraiment d'actualité puis encore
je vois tellement de monde encore
aujourd'hui et hésiter parle quand on
parle de quotas qu'on parle de tout ce
qui est ce qu on rajoute des femmes
juste parce que c'est des femmes et que
je suis important d'en parler de la
parité qui est pour moi c'est essentiel
d'avoir une assemblée nationale qui
composé à 50% de 50% fin il ya une chose
dont on parle beaucoup c'est de la
famille dans cette élection dont les
familles sont très courtisés et vous
avez deux enfants
oui d enfance de jeunes enfants qui vont
à la gare de ris encore
virons on se sent courtisé mais on se
sent dans des vases comme une plots et
non communiquée aux on sent que du
clientélisme qui se fait puis on fait
des petites mesures pour chaque client
at-elle comme sûre mais globalement ce
que vous trouvez que les partis font des
efforts pour attirer pour faire plaisir
aux familles oui c'est ça je pense
qu'ils cherchent à y chercher des
bonbons des petits cadeaux mais encore
là moi je trouve que pas de vision dans
l'ensemble et surtout pas de vision à
long terme
je trouve ça intéressant quand même ce
qui t'amène par rapport au fait que peu
de projets à long terme de société puis
je pense que c'est beaucoup ça en fait
qu' une réticence auprès des jeunes de
voter parce que on le sait on est là
pour plusieurs années encore avec dans
ses systèmes de vote et puis on se rend
compte que une fois en quatre ans on
nous promet elle en ce moment c'est la
famille on le sait le les 55 ans et plus
et une grosse majorité de la population
donc on va parler de santé parce que si
j'enlève ont voté pour nos prochaines
élections mais il manque un projet
d'ensemble qui est un projet qui réunit
tout ça c'est pas juste de dire à cette
partie de la population est en majorité
et on veut parler de santé parce que ça
les concerne
si je pense que je peux proposer quelque
chose qui englobe le tout je pense
qu'une des bonnes propositions au niveau
du long terme ce serait au niveau
peut-être la transition énergétique
je trouve que ça apporte autant du côté
de l'économie que de l'environnement les
transports en commun il ya plein de
dangereux qui sont reliés à ce nom
qu'ils voudraient c'est ça parle un peu
plus haut niveau de vie et ça serait
plus un projet de société qui vous
interpellent le projet société il ya
certains partis qui sont un peu plus
engagés dans ce niveau là mais par
exemple à la politique sur le plan de la
biomasse est proposée par québec
solidaire donc cdc des idées qui qui
touche tout le monde mais qui sont sur
le long terme et qui permettrait de la
création d'emplois et un environnement
plus que les chefs de parti benoit vous
parle de la bonne façon s'adresse à la
jeunesse de la bonne façon pas vraiment
j'ai l'impression parce qu'on nous on
nous parle beaucoup en chiffres en fait
moi j'ai besoin d'eux
d'un discours qui soutient je parlais de
clientélisme c'est un peu si on parle d'
enveloppe tant d'argent pour les ch et
celle des temps d'argent pour les boîtes
à lunch pour les jeunes mes enfants qui
ont deux ans et demi puis quatre mois ça
va être quoi l'héritage qu'on va leur
laisser dans land is an dans 20 ans
travolta est ce qu'on parle uniquement
du fonds des générations pour me
satisfaire actuellement 10 ha il y aura
de l'argent pour les jeunes dans le
futur non je pense qu' il faut des
projets pour améliorer laquelle leur
qualité de vie d'entraîneur de 40 à 50
vanessa pour conclure y reste trois
semaines de campagne qui jouent moins
qu'est ce que vous voudriez entendre des
chefs mais moi j'aime bien
j'aimerais que les autres chefs sa
position un peu plus peut-être au niveau
de la réduction des gaz à effet de serre
on a des gros enjeux qui s'en viennent
là dessus j'entendais françois legault
dire qu'ils avaient peur que ses enfants
ne parle plus français dans quelques
années
moi ce qui me fait plus peur c'est que
nos petits enfants ne puissent pas avoir
une qualité de vie intéressante parce
que les changements climatiques font
raser une partie de la planète
ça fait un peu alarmiste comme ça même
si c'est plus ce mets mes préoccupations
mais les gammes trois semaines de
campagne que ce que vous aimeriez
entendre moi j'aimerais entendre parler
de français et il y en ait un débat
électoral qui se passe en anglais mais
je trouve ce jugement aberrant je veux
dire 90 % de la population québécoise
parle français
pourquoi on aurait besoin par un débat
en anglais et crois pas parce que le
québec ça je pense que ça se passe en
français au québec
la langue officielle style français ça
me préoccupe un peu plus
ouais ok le mot pour terminer qu'est ce
que vous aimeriez en temps des trois
prochaines semaines devant de nos
cheveux mais d'abord quand justement
qu'on arrête de me parler en chiffres
puis compare un peu plus directement
concéderait samoa voici mon projet clair
de société et non juste on va vous
donner ta on va vous donner ta dans
khadra
alors qu'on a eu 30 ans d'arrière pourri
par la cbi réfléchir pourquoi l'eau
aujourd'hui de la prochaine élection
demain matin vous seriez capable
d'investir temps d'un panda sein du si
peu dans du si petit court terme par les
mois sur le long terme
voilà merci beaucoup à vous trois